the new year could give you new ways to
improve your regular visits to the
doctor Americans top resolutions for
2018 may not be a huge surprise 37% want
to eat healthier and get more exercise
24% plan to take better care of
themselves for many that means an annual
physical
the average doctor's visit lasts twenty
two minutes our doctor Tara Narula is
here with a checklist to make sure your
exam time is used wisely doc good
morning good morning New Year happy New
Year to you all right what should we be
doing in this visit to the doctor to
make it more worthwhile right 22 minutes
goes very quickly so you want to be
empowered and that means coming armed
with information so first you want to
bring your medications bring the bottles
bring pictures of the bottles so the
doctor knows the dosage and frequency
talk to your family before your visit a
skidooed your aunt Fran have a thyroid
problem does your mother have high blood
pressure that's very important you also
want to get copies of all your records I
can't tell you how many people have no
idea what their chest x-ray showed that
they had a year ago or their stress
tests that information is very useful
keep those copies bring all that
information to your visit and then you
want to keep a diary of your symptoms so
when did they start what do they feel
like all of that will be helpful and
last but not least you may want to bring
a friend or family member who can help
take notes and listen because lots of
times when you're in the office the
information goes in one ear and out the
other you're very overwhelmed having
someone there who can kind of
corroborate symptoms add information and
keep notes as useful it is not always
easy to transfer those records back and
forth and track them down right it is
not but you can ask for copies I mean
that is that is your right and you
should ask for a copy of your records
and have it with you is it useful to get
lab tests done before you actually go
for the checkup sometimes so if you're a
patient who's been with a doctor for a
while and you know every year they order
these tests or you're followed for a
condition like your thyroid or your
blood sugar then getting it before can
be helpful because you can then sit face
to face the doctor and go over the
results when you see them however for if
you're a new patient the doctor may want
to order specific tests particular to
whatever condition they're they're
looking at you for and then you would
get stuck twice essentially so it may
make sense to wait in that case what are
some of the questions you should ask so
you certainly want to ask things about
screening about vaccination prevention
your cardiovascular risk you want to ask
how the doctor's office functions how
they're gonna follow up with you how
often you should be seen
but I really think with those first
visits the most important thing is
establishing a connection this is like a
marriage it's a very important personal
relationship you're emotionally
vulnerable you're physically vulnerable
you want to know is this someone who's
going to listen to me who communicates
in a way that I understand and who
responds to my concerns in a way that's
appropriate what is the latest thinking
and what is your thinking on the annual
checkups and how often you should see
your doctor so there are pros and cons I
mean there there is evidence that says
it really doesn't decrease death or
illness it can waste time and money it
can lead to kind of overdiagnosis and
overtreatment on the other hand it again
establishes that very important
doctor-patient relationship that trust
and time is valuable so when you see
someone year to year you can tell you
know what they don't really seem the
same maybe there is some underlying
depression going on that mold that I saw
last year is a little bit different this
year so that's valuable it can also give
you time to go over prevention and
screening which is important yeah I
think the prevention is good too because
they always take your cholesterol your
blood pressure or get certainly ATS yeah
and certainly if you're getting older
and your blood pressure goes up and your
cholesterol goes up you can treat that
early and don't worry about asking for
second opinions you know people lots of
times feel uncomfortable about that but
the bottom line is this is your health
you need to be in charge and the doctor
should not get offended if you ask for a
second opinion right thank you thank you
very much